I had one kid say you're famous and I
said oh I'm not at all famous compared
to Michael Jackson the kid said not that
kind of famous art famous bow that kind
of fascinating
I'm William Wegman and most people know
me as the dog photographer
[Music]
I've been working with white Marauders
for over 45 years if I had a better
voice I compose a song about all the
dogs I've had verse there was man ray
and then came Fay Wray but I won't
burden you with that now I have two dogs
Flo and her brother topper and they're
really hello Flo
they're pretty amazing together
in my photographs what I like people to
see is that yes there's a dog and yes
it's a Weimaraner but what has it become
the dogs are always in a state of
becoming something they become
characters objects when they're lying
down there they're becoming landscapes
they let you do it it's something
special it's something unique it happens
only when we go to the studio and
there's an arena established for this
activity I live in Chelsea area of New
York I have this really great studio and
tons of props stored in the basement I'm
gonna need to go down and get those
vests ball gowns and ugly stepsister
outfits doodads and crazy hats and wigs
and all kinds of things I'm seeing
something on the floor Hawk gotta use
that put that on the dog's head
some people are alarmed when they see
human hands attached to the arms I like
that because it's almost like mythology
you know an Egyptian god with a bird
head and human hands well we really only
need that so I'll just try that I really
need that energy of the lights the
camera the the focus good girl
[Music]
my work sort of jumped out of the art
world into everybody's world I've seen
my work appear on the whole array of
things children's books videos for
Sesame Street films all kinds of things
it was a time when I felt like I was
nailed to the dog cross I wanted to to
escape that now kind of comfortable with
that and I feel really lucky to to have
this I think these might be my last two
dogs I'm in my 70s and I'll be in my 80s
when they're gone do I really want to
burden my family with other dogs I don't
know it's up to them when I'm 95 and
they want another dog okay I'll get one
[Music]
when he goes out and actually deploys to
chase something it looks like a missile
launch I just opened up the back door
and he jumps out it's a lot of fun Piper
is the only dog working at this airport
and there's actually only a handful of
dogs working at airports around the
country it's a pretty rare thing I'm
Brian Edwards Piper and I work at the
Cherry Capital Airport in Traverse City
Michigan Piper is a Border Collie
Piper's prime function here is wildlife
control primarily a piper is going to be
chasing away large waterfall like ducks
and geese in the wintertime that
actually chases away the snowy owl and
then in the summertime it's basically
seagulls and crows birds can cause a lot
of different types of damage most bird
strikes are with smaller types of birds
that might just cause dents but if the
bird is large enough and is ingested
into an engine that can cause a serious
failure like the Miracle on the Hudson
[Music]
training specifically for us took about
a year year and a half so the way that
we've trained is that anytime I deploy
Piper out of the truck he doesn't just
run away from the truck he always runs
the direction we were traveling a lot of
times I deploy him when the vehicle is
moving so that's just the way that we
trained that a lot of times I try to get
him to see what it is he's gonna chase
first the goggles are the rexspecs serve
two purposes for him one they're UV
protectant so they protect his eyes and
number two they're our safety goggles
basically it's one of those things that
if he wants to go out and work or have
fun and that he's got to wear it
dogs are really useful for wildlife
control because specifically border
cause it's in their blood eventually the
goal is to train the birds and other
animals that they don't want to be here
because there's a predator in town
something that's gonna keep harassing
them all the time
Piper's been with me at the airport for
almost three years he's pretty much with
me all the time
I don't think Piper sees it as work I
think it's all played to him well which
is what we want right the best thing
personally with Piper and it's been this
way before we started working he's got a
mind of his own
I talked to him like I would talk to
anybody else he's my bro it doesn't get
any better than that
I get to work with my best friend every
day I'm extremely proud of him I
couldn't ask for anything more
[Music]
[Music]
Blakely has the most difficult job in
Cincinnati Zoo he has to play with
babies all the time he's never shown any
aggression or snapped if he gets upset
kind of like any mom would he just
leaves the room my name is dawn Strasser
and we're at the Cincinnati Zoo and
Botanical Gardens Blakely is a 5 year
old Australian Shepherd we got him from
a rescue and I use him in a nursery as a
nanny or a companion dog this is about
you and your taking a nap blakeley's
here for the main purpose of teaching
the babies the correct animal cues as
they grow up so when they are introduced
back to their own kind they know what
appropriate behavior is he teaches them
how to play how to interact I can tell
them no don't bite me but I'm not an
animal
and I don't give the same cues that he
can so we make a great team
[Music]
Blakely has worked with cheetahs ocelots
a-talkin Bedard foxes a warthog
Wallabies
to name a few he's working with four
baby cheetahs right now it's been a long
seven weeks for him with these little
cheetah cubs and he's I think tired
because he's on alert for 24 hours a day
if they start making too much noise
he'll come and get us like something's
not right something's not right he's
kind of like a second set of eyes for us
too a lot of times they still recognize
each other like Dale the talk and he
raised when they see each other he'll
they'll still run up in front and grunt
at him and he'll kind of jump up on the
wall and kind of like hey how you doing
thank you yeah well I like to think I
have an office but I'm pretty sure it's
his
[Music]
one core trait in every dog is its ever
forgiving nature that's probably the
most valuable thing in a dog and it's
also its biggest pitfall because we have
dogs here who've been horribly hurt by
human beings and yet all I wanted was
find somebody else to look around the
world strays mutts and street dogs are
victims of stigma in Costa Rica Leah
battle is trying to change that story
she runs the territorio de su Gua taste
it's a lush haven for stray dogs to
either be adopted or to live out the
rest of their days the reptilians are
what this stands for land of the month
my name is Leah babbles better known as
crazy dog lady I guess I started 30 30s
I got this partly because I've always
loved animals all animals but it wasn't
in my plans it wasn't like I set out to
do this the need for this I think all
over the world is because there's a huge
stigma around a dog that doesn't have a
breed they'll let mutts wander on the
streets or they'll actually toss them on
the streets because they're not breed
dogs the solution isn't euthanizing a
dog the solution is make sure it's not
born in the first place once it's here
do something good for it find a home or
if not at least offer him a place where
you can be in peace and happy keeping
territorial up and running is no easy
feat they eat $500 a day in food alone
leah has to work a full-time job to keep
all the dogs fed and healthy territorial
stays about partly through miracles I
think keeping this afloat is a huge task
it's a labor of love
you can't pay someone to care for an
animal truly to remember their names to
be gentle to them while this place is a
dog heaven
nothing beats getting adopted by a
loving family I'd say it's like kids at
kindergarten they love their friends at
school but oh they all want to go home
to mom and dad
[Music]